Welcome to CloudEvents
with Google Cloud.
My name is Grant Timmerman.
I'm an engineer on Google
Cloud, where I primarily work on
serverless and open source.
In the next 25 minutes,
we'll be talking
about the rise of microservices
in serverless computing,
CloudEvents as application
an industry standard
for communicating events between
services, Events for Cloud Run,
how you can deliver events
directly to your application,
and finally, we'll be showing
the developer experience, along
with a demo.
First, let's give a background
to event driven architectures
by talking about the
rise of microservices.
Why microservices?
Well, it's easy to
describe with an example.
Here we have Bob's Big Bad
Monolith with these effects.
Your application has a global
state, increasing complexity.
There is often
complicated orchestration
with non-uniform communication
between services.
There's group scaling,
with services scaling up
based off demand of
one private servers.
There's coupled dependencies,
with library dependency
applying to all services.
And it's often
difficult to test,
heavily requiring box,
slow, often closed source.
So in effect, the
application does not
follow the single
responsibility principle,
and can sort of be described
like a Swiss Army knife.
That's compared to Mary's
Orchestrated Microservice where
we have the following upside.
You have local state
with reduced complexity.
A request and response
model, where you have
clear boundaries of ownership.
Only pay when
receiving an event.
Individual scaling
and loose binding.
Dynamic demand can increase
servers capacity independently
of each other.
Local development and
testing is quick and easy.
And you can easily
configure access management
with granular
security per service.
We're in a world
where applications
are moving towards real
time communication.
Well, what does this mean?
It means rapid delivery and
consumption of services.
So event driven
architecture often
requires immediate responses.
You have many to many messages,
where modern applications
expect to produce and
consume many events
from a variety of sources, as
well as a desire for on demand
scalability and cost, where
moderate applications see
dynamic traffic, but really
expect to see decreased costs.
So once you have decoupled
microservices services
how do these microservices
communicate with each other?
Well, through events.
What is an event?
In programming, an event
is an action or occurrence
recognized by software.
It often originates
asynchronously
from an external environment.
The publisher of the
event has no expectation
about how the event is handled.
The consumer of the
event decides what
to do with the notification.
And events are discrete units.
They are isolated and
independent from each other.
What is an event
driven architecture?
Well, it's based off of
indirect notification
with an intermediary or broker.
It can deliver the full event
data or just a reference
to the external
location, doesn't matter.
It can be found.
This is compared
to direct polling
between different services and
service oriented architectures
providing direct access to APIs.
While you can't really create
a real time system, as well.
[INAUDIBLE]
Very hard.
So events make
applications complicated.
But in practice,
developers simply want
to make applications
work and not
really think about
conceptual eventing systems.
Managing events is
important but cumbersome.
As a developer, you have
questions like, what happened?
What type of event did I get?
Who sent the event?
Where is the event from?
When was the event sent?
Is it a duplicate?
Is it created recently?
And moreover, every event
has its own different format.
What if there was a
common machine readable
standard for events?
Well, introducing the
CloudEvents specification,
a common way for
describing events.
Here's the premise.
Events are everywhere,
yet event publishers
tend to describe
events differently,
especially with
respect to burgeoning,
[INAUDIBLE] formats and subtle
payload differences that
may break your application.
So CloudEvents is
the specification
for describing event
data in a common way.
It's brought to you by the Cloud
Native Computing Foundation
serverless working
group, a group
of developers across the
computing industry creating
standards for more
compatible services.
At the core, CloudEvents
is an envelope
for information about
the occurrence of change
in a system.
I like to think of
it like a one way
letter with a from
address and no to address.
The CloudEvents format has
the following properties.
CloudEvents carry
facts and metadata
with standard attributes.
They do not prescribe what
you do with these facts.
They are self-contained,
meaning you
don't need to attach any
information to the event.
It's the whole picture.
The event format itself
is lightweight and unique
within a source.
You can encode them
in different formats
without losing and modifying
information, such as JSON,
BSON, Avro, et cetera.
And doesn't talk about
any HTTP methods,
API services, just talks
about the HTTP mapping.
I think it's really easiest
to understand CloudEvents
by seeing some examples.
Let's say we're a web
application on top of GCP.
Here we have some
example events that you
might see in your application.
A new photo is uploaded.
A new generic message is
published to the topic.
Could be a new user.
Or a new audit log is recorded.
Whatever it may be, a new VM
is spun up in the project.
These are different
events you might see.
So as a developer, I
have some questions
about the event being
delivered to my system.
What kind of event did I get?
When was it sent?
Who sent it to my service?
What's the event's
unique identifier?
What is the shape
of the event data?
And what is the event data?
Well, this corresponds
to the following comment
fields of type, time,
source ID, dataschema,
and the data fields.
Now if we fade out
the question and left
align the properties,
you [INAUDIBLE]
and specify the
version of the payload
with the specversion
property, add some data,
we get a CloudEvent.
This is an example of CloudEvent
that you might see from PubSub.
Some more about the spec
can be seen on GitHub.
Let's dive deeper into
that specification.
Every CloudEvent has a set
of required and optional
attributes.
There are four required
ones with some examples.
The ID, which is a string,
identifies the event.
The source plus
ID must be unique.
The source as a URI
identifies the context.
The specversion, the string.
The CloudEvent specversion
to be used with that event,
like 1.0 or 0.3.
Then you have the time-
the type attribute,
which is a string, a value
identifying the type of event.
The CloudEvents may have
some optional attributes
in this format.
You can have data.
Well, it can be
anything, as long
as it's domain
specific information
about the occurrence.
The data content
type is a string.
The MiME Media Type RFC 2046,
such as application JSON.
You have your data schema,
which is a URI that identifies
the schema, the data attribute.
In Google's case,
we use Proto's.
Subject is a string, is
the subject of event.
It's really useful
for filtering.
And time is the timestamp,
the time of when
the occurrence happened.
Other attributes are allowed,
just not standardized.
There are two primary
modes for including
CloudEvents [INAUDIBLE]
via the HTTP protocol,
use binary encoding or
structured encoding.
These are called content
modes in the CloudEvent
specification.
Let's go over them.
Here on the right hand side,
we have an HTTP request
of the CloudEvent
using binary encoding.
At the top you see an
HTTP post to slash,
with some standard
HTTP attributes.
There's some context
attributes with the HTTP header
prefix of ce dash, you're
free to add other headers too.
And then you have
the CloudEvent body,
which is the full HTTP body.
This encoding is used
by events for Cloud Run.
That's compared to the
structural encoding where
we have context attributes
under the first level
properties of the JSON object.
And the data attribute
under the data property.
This encoding is used by
Cloud Functions, for example.
So what does this
look like in practice?
Well your service will
receive an HTTP request.
Within that HTTP
request is a CloudEvent.
Then, within that CloudEvent
you have some metadata,
use CloudEvent standard
attributes and your event
payload.
Well that's the CloudEvent.
It should be very clear
what a CloudEvent is.
Let's go and move on.
Now let's talk about
events for Cloud Run.
Cloud Run is a fully
managed computing platform
for deploying, scaling,
to analyze applications
quickly and securely.
Use any language, abstract
infrastructure management,
with a simple
developer experience.
It's built on the
open Knative standard.
Events for Cloud Run
makes it easy to connect
your applications from
a variety of sources.
And it takes care of event
integration, delivery,
security authorization,
with error handling for you,
which all in all
improves developer
agility and your
application's resilience.
The long term vision is to
be able to deliver events
from a variety of sources to
Cloud Run and custom sinks.
Currently you can deliver
events from Google Cloud sources
via Cloud Audit Logs or
Pub/Sub, to Cloud Run.
Going back to the event examples
we had described before,
whenever a new file is
uploaded to Cloud Storage,
a new message is being
published to the Pub/Sub.
Or a new Audit Log is created.
Now triggering Cloud
Run services directly
from events, via
Events for Cloud Run.
The way Events for Cloud
Run works is like this.
You can trigger your service
from a variety of sources,
Cloud Storage,
Pub/Sub, [? Cal, ?]
And your events will go
through Events for Cloud Run.
And this will send an HTTP
request to your Cloud Run sink
with a Cloud Run payload.
Let's break that apart.
On the left you have some
event producers, our sources.
With sources you can
describe the event sources,
describe the event types, list
and describe all event types.
In the center you have
a Cloud Run service
where you can go and
manage your triggers,
you can create new triggers,
specifying the event source.
For example, Cloud
Services via Cloud Audit
Logs, or a custom
applications via Pub/Sub.
And you have your
CRUD operations
for triggers like
listing triggers,
deleting triggers and
describing triggers.
These triggers specify why your
sink, which is your Cloud Run
service, specified by name.
The three modes of interaction
for configuring Events
for Cloud Run use the Cloud
Console UI, the Cloud CLI
or REST API.
Let's go over them.
With the Cloud-- the Events
for Cloud Run UI allows you
to easily create
triggers just on cloud--
console.cloud.google.com.
Simply specify your event
source, create and done.
Currently they'll be
using the Cloud CLI
after installing the alpha
components in GCloud.
Just type gcloud alpha
events to get started.
Zooming into the
alpha events command,
we specify the trigger
name, the target service
and the event type.
And we have some
optional parameters
used for filtering like
the service name, method
name and resource name.
In this case, this is a command
used for Google Cloud Storage.
Lastly you can use the Cloud
Run API if you really want.
You might be asking, what's the
difference between Cloud Run
for Anthos and Fully Managed.
What's the difference?
The differences are here.
In summary, Fully Managed
has a simpler trigger setup,
is Google managed, but has
fewer events sources currently.
And you can only trigger
Cloud Run services,
not any Kubernetes
service or arbitrary URLs.
TLDR, use events
for GKE using GKE.
Next we'll be running
through the developer
experience, and
some useful tools
when using Events for Cloud Run.
First off is the
CloudEvents SDK.
The CloudEvent SDKs
are a lightweight set
of libraries
designed to speed up
your integration
with CloudEvents
within your application.
They can do three things.
You can create CloudEvents,
send CloudEvents
and receive CloudEvents,
a language [INAUDIBLE]..
There's a spec on GitHub.
Practically speaking,
this means that you
can transform your HTTP
request from this to this,
extracting the
CloudEvent object.
These SDKs are available in the
following languages, in Node,
Go, Python, Java,
Ruby, PHP and .Net.
The code is open
source on GitHub.
And here's a little
disclaimer here, [INAUDIBLE]
way I can use these
images, trust me.
So within a CloudEvent,
each event type
has its own data format.
So what's the
structure of that data?
Well we've described
the Source of Truth
for the structure of
the data in Protobufs.
These Protobufs contain
the CloudEvent type,
which is a string, and
the CloudEvent data,
which is the full
message description.
On right hand side, you can see
an example of a Protobuf used
for Cloud Console.
These have been
published to GitHub.
We'll be adding more event
types as new ones are supported.
Based off of the Source
of Truth as mentioned,
we have language
and code binding
in seven different languages.
These provide types
like structs in Go,
TypeScript interfaces
in Node, POJOs in Java.
In terms of getting
started, we have
a set of quick start
examples in these languages.
As well as two simple
applications and a Codelab.
Lets say we're a movie studio
recording a lot of audio.
We have hundreds of audio
files being recorded every day.
How can we search
through these audio files
and find the texts in these
files being spoken, maybe
in real time?
So the idea is whenever I upload
an audio file to Google Cloud
storage, then let's use Cloud
Speech to Text to extract
the text from the audio file.
And then add the results
to Google Sheets.
Let's go to [INAUDIBLE] VS
Code, where we can see the demo.
Now we're going to show
a quick demo and then
dive into the code.
On the left hand side you'll
see Google Spreadsheet.
And on the right
hand side, you'll
see a Google Cloud
have Storage Bucket.
I'm going to pass some
files and then upload them
into our Google
Cloud Storage Bucket.
These are some audio files of
me speaking Chinese and English.
And so you'll see on
the left hand side,
we have uploaded
these files and it's
been added to our spreadsheet.
In fact all the audio has been
recognized and transcribed
into text.
[SPEAKING CHINESE], et cetera.
That's really cool.
How did we do that?
Well, let's go
dive into the code.
We use Events for Cloud Run.
But first, let's talk
about our Cloud Run server.
So we provided a
Dockerfile just specifying
our base image of Node: 14.
And we're going to
[INAUDIBLE] start,
with the Screen Express app.
Here we have just a front
slash, a health check.
And then a slash
for post request
we extract the CloudEvent
from the HTTP headers
and then we can get the bucket
name and the object name
from the CloudEvent subject.
And then we use the
bucket and object
names to get the actual speech.
So what this is doing is it's
calling this file, speech.js,
and then calling the
Speech-to-Text function.
So there's the bucket
and the file name.
It downloads the file and
then it reads the file locally
and AudioBytes and Base64.
And then now we're going
to prepare our request
to the Cloud Speech-to-Text API.
So we're going to
provide the AudioBytes.
We're going to provide
LINEAR16 encoding
since this is a wav file.
We're primarily trying
to understand Chinese,
so our language code is zh-CN.
But we also want to
recognize English
and so we provide the alternate
language codes of English.
Then we call the API
and we join the result.
And then we just want
the actual string.
Let's return that.
Next we're going--
with that result,
we go and add a new row.
How do we do this?
Well we have a different
file, sheets.js.
We provide a spreadsheet ID.
Here we have an
add row function.
Here we use a service
account credentials,
we put a local file we
downloaded, creds.js,
and we provide the
spreadsheets scope.
We've already shared
the Google Spreadsheet
with the service account email.
So it has access to that
spreadsheet that's private.
And then we append some values.
So with that spreadsheet ID, and
the range [INAUDIBLE] needed,
we're going to provide
a 2D array of value.
Which is just the
array of our results.
And so we just
append the values,
and then we say, 200 OK,
to the Cloud Run API.
We're all good.
And that's it.
Now, how did I
create my trigger?
Well you can see, Cloud
Run, it's really great
how triggers are separate
from your service
so that you can
create and delete
triggers without having
to redeploy your service.
So we can see here, if we go
and list all of our triggers,
we have a trigger here set up.
And in fact we can go
create one like [INAUDIBLE]
before of simply creating a
new trigger that's separate.
Maybe we want to make a
separate trigger like this.
And then it's really quick and
easy, in my opinion at least.
It takes two or three
seconds and then it works.
Sometimes it takes a little
bit longer, but done.
And that's how you
create a trigger.
And then you can list
all your triggers.
And that's [INAUDIBLE] the demo.
Hope you liked it.
I think my Chinese college
professor would be proud,
and thanks.
What we just saw was a demo of
deploying a Cloud Run Service,
creating an event trigger.
We uploaded some audio files
on Google Cloud Storage Bucket,
which then fired
an event, creating
a request to Cloud Run.
Which uses the Google
Speech-to-Text API
plus the Google Sheets API.
So in summary, we talked about
the rise of microservices,
the CloudEvents specification,
Events for Cloud Run,
and a demo experience.
Sign up for a private
preview today.
Here are some links to sign
up for Cloud Run and Cloud Run
on GKE.
Public preview is
in September, 2020.
Thanks so much.
My name is Grant.
You can tweet at me,
@GrantTImmerman on Twitter,
or check out my code
at GitHub.com/Grant.
Don't forget to
smile, all right?
And I hope you have
a fantastic next.